TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to "The Developer Show."
This is your TL;DR.
Defer actions until the
user has stable connectivity
with the new web
API Background Sync.
Check out how with
the link below.
It just became a
lot easier to see
any issues you have
with certificates
and mixed content with
the Security Panel
introduced with Chrome 48.
The blog post and video have
details on how to use it.
Learn how to use
JavaScript Promises
for deferred and asynchronous
computation with this course
built in collaboration
with you Udacity.
Happy 100th blog
post, Apps Script.
Thanks for helping
developers create add-ons
for Google Sheets,
Docs, or Forms,
automate their
workflows, integrate
with external APIs, and more.
Here's a few recent
posts to celebrate.
Tips and best practices for
developing more complex Apps
Scripts solutions.
A new calendar resource
API that enables
Google for Work
customers to manage
their physical resources,
like conference rooms
and printers, or even nap
pods and tennis courts.
And the latest version
of the Google Drive
API for a leaner, faster by
default, and more consistent
interface to Google Drive.
And although not exactly
developer-related,
I just thought this was
a really cool article
about a group of
doctors that used
Google Cardboard to
visualize the anatomy
of a four-month-old girl
before a life-saving surgery.
Just a reminder that the stuff
we're all working on together
can have a real impact
on people's lives.
And finally, Lenovo
and Google recently
announced a partnership
to create a new mainstream
smartphone with
Project Tango built in.
Which, of course, if
you haven't already,
makes it a great time to
get to know Project Tango.
So we thought for
the rest of the show,
we'd hang out with
the Project Tango
team at their latest developer
workshop in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm standing here with
Johnny Lee, who many of you
may recognize from
his YouTube video--
the head tracking
with the Wii remotes--
and now you're the Technical
Program Lead for Project Tango.
JOHNNY LEE: Indeed.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
is Project Tango,
and what can it mean for users?
JOHNNY LEE: Yeah, so if you
think about your ability
to walk through your house,
to walk to your office,
you have this amazing
ability that you've
evolved where you
use your eyesight,
and you use some
of your information
from your inner ear to be
able to get from room to room,
and get to your living
room, walk down the hallway.
And that information is
meaningful to you and to me,
but our devices--
like our phones--
really don't have that same
sense of physical space.
So what we've been
doing with Project Tango
is trying to give our tools
this human-scale sense of space
and motion.
And we do that with a
combination of sensors
and software
[? stacks. ?] So, there's
a special set of
cameras that are built
into the mobile
device, and we run
a software library on Android
that does the sensor fusion.
And we get an accurate,
six degree of freedom
position of the
device in real time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's huge.
JOHNNY LEE: So you
can almost think of it
like it's a 3D mouse, right?
When you move it, it goes
up and down, left and right,
and you can rotate it.
And you can use it to track your
position throughout the room.
And that enables things like
VR and AR applications--
[? style ?] applications-- but
through a little magic window
instead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Here I am with
Eric Johnson, Head of Business
Development for Project Tango.
Hi, Eric.
ERIC JOHNSON: Hey, Timothy.
How's it going?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's going well.
So I wanted to talk to you
about Project Tango, obviously.
We're here in San
Francisco at a developer
workshop for Project Tango.
Developers are building
really cool applications
out there, some of which
we'll see in a little bit.
But to start with, what's
the big thing that's
happened in Project Tango that's
motivating developers the most
right now?
ERIC JOHNSON: So last
week we announced
we have a mass-market consumer
phone coming this summer.
And so that's really the
exciting thing that I think
has woken up the ecosystem.
People have been aware
of Project Tango,
but now that it's real--
there's real hardware coming--
developers are much more
excited about building something
for that experience
when the phone ships.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, and I
mean mass-market consumer phone
sounds like a big thing, but
the practical elements of this
is that developers have been
experimenting and playing
with Tango.
But now actual users are
going to have actual phones
in their pockets this summer.
ERIC JOHNSON: That's
right, exactly.
And so what we're
doing in parallel
is we're hosting developer
workshops every month.
And this is one example, this
one here in San Francisco.
This one happens to be focused
on location-based experiences.
So Tango does a number of
things, one of the things
that it does is provides
indoor location and navigation.
And so we've got some
awesome brands here.
We've got some
retail brands, we've
got Google teams
that are here, we've
got developers that work in
the location-based environment.
We've got robot companies.
And they're all
collaborating together,
and it's awesome to see the
demos that are coming out
of these workshops.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Now if a developer was really
interested in Project Tango,
and they wanted to take
it to the next level,
I hear you have
an app incubator.
Is that right?
ERIC JOHNSON: That's right.
We just announced that
last week as well,
when we announced the
Lenovo phone at CES.
And I think you're going
to show the website here.
We encourage people
to go to that website,
check out the app
incubator, read the details.
And that's really
where we're looking
to go for more of the
deep experience we
have with our current
app developers
and broaden that out,
encourage more developers
to work with us.
And then from that
we're investing in some,
we're inviting
some to workshops,
we're looking to highlight
some at Google I/O,
some as we launch the phone.
So that's really the
place that people
want to go to learn about
developing on Project Tango.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
All right, Eric.
Well, I think we're
going to talk to Johnny.
We're going to check
out some demos.
ERIC JOHNSON: All
right, sounds good.
Thanks for coming up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
think there's a lot
to be excited about
with Project Tango.
But this is one of
those platforms where
I wonder if there's some
things where you didn't realize
that they would be as cool as
they actually were once you
actually played with them.
Is there anything like that?
JOHNNY LEE: We built a lot
of simple code with our SDK,
or tried to provide as
much sample code as we can.
And so one of our
engineers decided
to make a little
virtual pet cat.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
I've seen this cat.
This cat is amazing!
JOHNNY LEE: Yeah, actually
it's disappointingly cute.
Or annoyingly cute,
I'll put it that way.
So it's a little 3D cat, he
runs around on the ground.
But it uses the sensors
to actually detect
where the floors are.
It can actually jump on your
bed and jump on the table,
and when you get close to the
cat, he'll paw at the screen.
It's really cute,
and you can show it
to people who are
unfamiliar with technology,
and they get engaged with it.
We picked a friendly cat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For more
information on Project Tango,
please check out
the links below.
You'll find a link to the
presentation at the Ubiquity
Dev Summit, as well as a
link to their app incubator.
And remember to come
back here every Friday
for a new episode of
"The Developer Show."
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]